إنه شعور مخيف جدًا بالنسبة لي
ولكل شخص يسمع عن هذا ما الذي
تبحث عنه وقد ذكرت فكرة
الكلام غير الواضح الذي ذكرته لفكرة
الشعور بالارتباك ، إذا كان هناك
فترة زمنية معينة أعرف ما إذا كان
لديك سكتة دماغية  اقرأ نوعًا ما
العلامات وهناك رياح من الفرص التي
من المفترض أن يتم توفير مخففات الدم
بطريقة ما لمنحك
فرصة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، هل هناك نافذة
تحتاج فيها إلى الوصول إلى المستشفى إذا
كنت تشعر بهذه الطريقة ،
نعم  يعني أن الشيء في هذا هو
هذه الأنواع من هذه النزيف التي تكون في
أعلى الدماغ عادةً إذا كان
هذا هو ما عانى منه
ويبدو أنه إذا وصلت إلى المستشفى
بسرعة بداخلك تعلم بسكتة دماغية ، فسيكون ذلك في
الحقيقة في غضون ثلاث ساعات مع هذا النوع
من الأشياء التي يجب أن تفكر فيها في الوصول إلى
هناك بأسرع ما يمكن أيضًا إذا كان
بإمكانك تخفيف الضغط عن
الدماغ وببساطة عن طريق إزالة بعض العظام
وإزالة مجموعة الدم هذه ، مما يؤدي إلى إزالة هذا
الضغط من الدماغ مثل  في أسرع وقت
ممكن تزيد فرص البقاء على قيد الحياة بشكل كبير ،
أعني أن
الأمر بسيط بقدر ما هو مجرد
مشكلة ضغط في تلك المرحلة مرة أخرى ليس لدى
الدماغ مكان يذهب إليه لأنه في
حالة على حدة ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنني أعتقد أن
الرسالة هي  مرة أخرى ، لا أريد أن
أخاف الناس والناس يصطدمون
برؤوسهم طوال الوقت واتضح
أنه لا شيء ولكن إذا كانت ضربة شديدة
على الرأس إذا كان لديك بعض هذه
الأعراض مرة أخرى ، فسأقول فقط إنك تعلم أن الأمر
يزداد سوءًا  الصداع ، الارتباك ، الغثيان ،
القيء ، الكلام
غير المعتاد ، أي شيء آخر غير معتاد مثل هذا إذا كنت تتناول
أدوية سيولة الدم ، وخاصة إذا كنت من
كبار السن ،
فهذه بالفعل تزيد
من فرصتك في تطوير شيء كهذا
مرة أخرى ، فهذا ليس شائعًا.
لا أريد أن أخاف الناس بلا داع ،
لكن هذه بعض المؤشرات
التي تدل على أنه يجب عليك فحص هذا في
بعض الأحيان ، سيكون مجرد
فحص عصبي في غرفة الطوارئ
أحيانًا.  ستحتاج إلى فحص القط ولكن
هناك طرق لتشخيص هذا
بسرعة وفعل شيء حيال ذلك بسرعة إذا كانت
هذه هي المشكلة